hey guys and welcome to episode number
22 of my road to one bill series today
we are going to be focusing on getting
the kill of Z cuz it's pissing me off
and I want to get that done to prove to
myself that it can be done and um at
least I can do it uh so what we're going
to start off by doing is training up our
Mage we're using the string jewelry
spell right now and we'll get some
quests done as well uh for the god capes
and uh yeah hope you guys enjoy and
let's get started all right we're just
about to hit a magic level and might
notice that this uh spell I'm using
string jewelry is actually a level 80
spell we are using magic potions uh it's
a little Annoying to do this but the
experience per hour we're getting is
definitely a weighing it so there 79
magic uh one more level for now and um
it's a little pricey to do this
otherwise this would be my go-to method
but it's about 500k to a mil an hour
depending on what jewelry you're buying
but it's pretty pricey all right and
here we're about to hit Level 80 magic
and that's what we're going to stop for
now uh these extra two magic levels are
kind of nice uh just gives you a nice
round number pretty well and now we're
going to go ahead and do some quests and
mainly just so we can get the god Cape
as well as the book of Darkness so we're
going to have to do horror from the deep
as well as um the Mage Arena mini game
uh so like I said earlier I want to get
the god capes unlocked and it's been way
too long uh you can get them a level 60
magic and I just haven't done it they're
really good for their slot plus 10 or 15
magic Bon is are extremely good so let's
go get them yeah it's pretty easy we're
just killing codon in his black teon
form right right now with the toxic
Trident it's a breeze I've only used
like one or two sharks uh but that being
said you're probably supposed to do this
at level 60 um but either way we're
going to get it eventually and after
this we'll go and do whr from the deep
all right there we go we got the sidon's
cape uh we're going to pick up probably
as many as we can uh well we got full
inventory of sharks but I think this is
the easiest way to do it just get a full
inventory and then you don't have to
come back later to get them uh cuz when
you do die well not in Z I think you
keep it but other places you will lose
it
uh so it's good to get a bunch but there
we go this should give us a nice boost
to our magic and now we'll go and get
the book of
Darkness uh so apparently to do horror
from the deep you do need to do the bar
crawl mini game uh which i' never heard
of or not mini mini quest uh but yeah
we'll go ahead and do this quickly I
guess you just go with all the bars and
RuneScape and get really drunk uh which
doesn't sound too bad at all all right
that was pretty accurate we're going
around and claiming some free drinks
actually they're not free uh but some
unique drinks getting drunk and filling
up our card all right there we go we
finished the mini game and I don't think
you get anything for actually finishing
this um but is a requirement for horror
from the deep as well as I think one
other quest uh but you'll let us in
there Perfect all right let's start the
quest I've never seen this place before
has a very cool set of rocks lading to
it huh this reminds me of some crazy
puzzle from an old Game Boy Advance game
all right there we go we got the horror
from the deep Quest started it sounded
like I was finishing it nope psych we're
just starting it right now and we'll go
ahead and finish it shortly all right we
just finished fixing the lighthouse and
a big Hound of frogs pack of frogs a
murder of frogs whatever a bunch of
frogs are harassing me I guess hey
sharks what are those doing there all
right we're just finishing up killing
the D enough mother uh we actually had
to go back and grab some other spells
cuz I was attacking it for about 10 15
tries and I realized it was not doing
damage uh but that's fine we got a bolt
spell from each of the elemental uh
Origins I guess all right there we go
ACC from the deep done uh we got a
little bit of experience I guess but
mainly uh we have unlocked the ability
to fill uh some of the god books so in
this particular case the book of
darkness is going to be the most useful
but we're going to grab a book from each
of the Gods um the zamra B is good but
since we're switching it for a toxic
Trident uh we won't really have another
book to switch into anyways we might as
well go for the book of Darkness cuz it
gives us the most Mage bonus all right
we bought the darkness page set off the
grand exchange uh probably efficient by
the individual pieces but [__] it uh
unpack it and let's toss those into our
book yeah there we go one in two in
three in and the last one there we go we
got our book of Darkness let's equip
this bad
boy and it's going to give us an
extra 10 magic which is still really
nice all right so I'm kind of in a
questing mood now uh having done a
couple key Quest we're going to go ahead
and bang out all the freeto playay
quests mainly because of the quest
points you gain from it cuz it's going
to give us an extra like 30 or 40 Quest
points cuz we are looking to do recipe
for disaster eventually and uh yeah
we're just going to do these cuz they're
really easy and uh they give you pretty
good Quest rewards at least in quest
points all right I barely barely have a
recollection of doing this Quest my
original account I just never understood
the Cabbage interaction with their soup
uh how how did this actually mess
anything up oh it's a magic cabbage okay
there we go that explains everything cuz
before I thought like just regular
cabbage out what is that doing it's a
magic cabbage okay that's
good sploosh all right there we go Black
Knight Fortress has been completed 2500
coins and three Quest points again that
was a five minute Quest and three Quest
points for that it's pretty good all
right next up is Demon Slayer and
honestly just recording this section to
just uh remember our incantation
incantation all right we're going to go
ahead and kill the demon
here and we're going to kill the wizard
first let's see can we one shot the
demon are we even going to be able to
kill it all it's going to be a pretty
intense fight we got lobsters we got
stamina potions we have a toxic Trident
but we have to use silver light can we
get the hit and one shot nice and now we
just have to toss in our incantation we
have a notepad that we actually wrote it
down on
carum
Aber car that
Pai and gindo
gindo all right there we go demon layer
has been completed demons have been
vanquished what are we going to get for
this it's like 4K oh my God this is
taking forever for this guy to
die kill him okay there we go I guess
just three Quest points and silver light
uh well silver light looks cool at least
all right next upep is going to be imp
catcher uh did a pretty Speedy run in
Catcher got all the beads of course
ahead of time and um yeah this Quest
honestly takes 30 seconds just get all
the items there we go one Quest point in
M am of accuracy uh achieved all right
next up is going to be the Pirates freet
to playay Quest can't remember what it's
called now anyway Redbeard Frank what do
you got for me you got a quest I'll
bring you some R okay all right there we
go pirates treasure Quest has been
completed two Quest points one ictor
treasure chest and you can now use pay
option to go with the kja some pretty
sweet rewards all right next up we're
going to do Prince alley rescue another
super easy fre play Quest we're actually
using a speedr running guide for this
one really know why but it just popped
up so let's go ahead and see how speedly
we can do this all right there we go the
Prince Ali Quest is done has another
three Quest points and 700 coins which
we will toss in the bank that is also
bringing us to 100 Quest points even but
halfway to recipe for disaster all right
now we got the easiest quest in the game
pretty much Romeo and Juliet No required
items almost and five Quest points we're
going to as a reward for this one that's
pretty hype there we go ROM and Juliet
done five Quest points achieved all
right there we go we're just finished up
ship cheer another super easy quest one
Quest Point 150 crafting experience and
I think we're just going to do witches
potion and leave the other two for now
um not for any particular reason but I
just don't feel like doing them all
right witchet potion is just about to be
completed and there we go that is 325
magic Experience One Quest point and
pretty much all the freeo play quests
done again we're going to do Shield of R
another day uh but yeah there we go lots
of quest points achieved all right so
many of you may have seen my attempt
from last episode which was extremely
pitiful now I've tried it about 10 times
that is killing Zora since then now we
do have the book of darkness in the god
Cape which is going to help out a little
bit so now we're going to go ahead and
do another temperature check on how well
I'm doing edor definitely have gotten
better not a successful kill yet but
we're getting pretty close um again what
I'm feeling that the most here I believe
is actually switching my prayer in time
and getting the actual rotation down um
beyond that I think I have enough items
and everything like see like this like I
[__] up changed my prayer uselessly
and I'm not actually going to get any
damage on Zora uh but I have gotten it
down to under 100 HP uh during one of my
runs uh so again we're not going for
efficiency we're just going for
completion uh again we didn't even drink
our potions before we started which is
just another simple mistake not sure why
we didn't do that uh anyway again a
little slow on moving over here we're
already like we should be H pretty much
there already and we're missing out a
lot of damage and taking too much damage
here of course I'm commenting on this
and post commentary so it's a lot easier
to see my mistakes now uh so again I
would appreciate constructive tips uh
please don't flame me too hard because
I'm not really inclined to this uh
something I'm learning and I'm really
striving to learn for you guys cuz I've
been spending a lot of time working
towards doing Zora and I can't abandon
that now so we're going to definitely
keep grinding this out until I get
efficient edit or at least passable U
well there we go got the switch down
there or at least we're standing by the
pillar we're doing a lot more right than
we have been in the past and this Run's
actually going pretty decent I would say
and for some reason um I guess I'm the
the guide of using for the rotations and
where to stand is just a little bit off
I've noticed I'm not actually at the I'm
at the correct spot but um I still
taking damage from the poison Cloud see
there again just way too late in the
rotation I'm wasting time misclick ran
into the poison like there just no
reason to do that uh one other thing I
need to work on is also Chang my toxic
blowpipe to the long range mode uh
because often times you won't actually
be able to get enough distance to attack
zor from the safe zone or you'll be
taking lots of damage from the poison
clouds and what we're take more damage
speaking of that and also have to
remember to drink prayer potions as I'm
uh running towards a new location cuz
here you can see my prayer is just about
to drop again post commentary a lot
easier to notice these things but yeah
my prayer almost dropped there we're
really close luckily didn't let that
happen again we shouldn't be riding our
health less low 37 still can be one shot
and yeah still a pretty solid run for me
getting pretty close to killing all
right here not quite going to happen I
don't think this run
uh 195 pretty low though and there we go
forgot to switch unfortunately I died
there but anyway getting a lot better
guys give me some time and we will
definitely get a kill oh I'm a Noob I
wasn't recording it but I did end up
getting a kill I think it was like a 4
minute kill yeah four minutes 2 seconds
and we got a shitty drop I don't care
I'm so hyped I actually killed zoraa
that's awesome I'm going to die cuz I
didn't even have an anti venom but I
don't even care that's so hype finally
got the zor kill even though it's
probably one of the worst drops possible
well not the worst 70k is still better
than nothing but my God after probably
like 20 to 25 kills I finally got not
kills 20 25 attempts I finally got a
kill woo all right guys that's going to
be the end for today's episode I hope
you did enjoy I finally got my first Z
kill uh which is awesome I'm getting the
hang of it finally uh I'm usually
getting pretty close to the end or
actually getting a kill um I'm up to
three kill counts so far my best time
being about 3 minutes and 3 seconds
uh which isn't terrible uh now of course
it doesn't outweigh the 50 odd deaths
I've received as well but yeah so thanks
for tuning in guys and I will see you
guys in episode number 23
[Music]